ça te manque le monde mais je connais
plein de monde j'ai du sang sur les
mains je suis
souilléess de toutes mes forces les gens
commenc à dire que tu es mon père je
peux pas eff
[Musique]
pass
12 il en manque
[Musique]
regarde vérifiez votre balance il en
manque 5 si tu négliges le moindre
détail tu ne
seraéche tu sais bien que ta grand-mère
va s'inquiéter tu pas mon père elle a
dit qu'
[Musique]
pas
on est
fermé tue la fille d'abord pour qu'il
voit fais-toi
plaisir pote qu'est-ce qu'il te
faut pour ta protection la chasse je
crois aux anges on a besoin de personne
pour nous sauver j'essaie seulement de
me sauver moi-même parfois on n'arrive
pas à savoir qui est
sauvé ils sont partis rapidement m gars
sont à la recherche du véhicule il passe
pas
l'appel qu'est-ce que vous faites avec
[Applaudissements]
eux il y a certaines choses qu'on peut
pas effacer malgré tous nos
[Musique]
efforts
il fallait que j'affronte mon passé je
prenne mes
responsabilités tu m'as dit de trouver
un moyen de faire la paix j'ai
[Musique]
trouvé